bienvenue dans le programme de stagiaires de Google,
eh bien, il ne s'agira pas de prendre du
café et de faire des courses pour les gens,
nous envisageons une sorte de jeux de la
faim mentale contre un groupe d'
enfants géniaux pour seulement une poignée d'emplois choisissez
vos thés j'ai vu un  beaucoup d'acteurs pour ce
groupe de cinq je voulais construire le
personnage autour de ce qu'ils sont et de ce
qu'ils ont apporté savez-vous comme Tobin
vient d'être diplômé de l'UCLA yo-yo que diriez-vous d'
un high five whoa il sait ce que c'est que d'
être une concentration intense  élève te ferais-
tu beaucoup battre à l'école j'ai
été scolarisé à la maison par ma mère te battrais-tu
beaucoup à l'école à la maison c'est une sorte de
parallèle parce que je viens en quelque sorte
du monde mais les personnages sont en
ce moment et puis j'ai trouvé  que je pouvais
vraiment comprendre et j'avais beaucoup de gens
qui ressemblent beaucoup à ceux
à cette table
ma mère dit que l'alcool engourdit le cerveau
peut-être que c'est un pas dans la bonne direction
Dylan a eu 21 ans il y a deux jours non y est
allé oh c'est là  tu sais c'est que le
gen  ration qui vit sur leurs écrans à
seulement trois pouces je vous en supplie
ouais toutes les questions que vous avez faites beaucoup d'
improvisation avec Vince lors de votre audition
n'est-ce pas vous voulez entendre quelque chose de
complètement fou, posez-le sur nous Big Daddy
bien et je pense beaucoup  de cela s'est produit
avec comme avec tous nos personnages
bien qu'ils aient un
entraînement de renard Brenner Oh totalement différent ouais ravi
de vous rencontrer je suis Lyle l'un des
chefs d'équipe me pilonne allez frère poing moi
me lève là ouais ce n'est certainement
pas  c'est vrai Josh est allé à Harvard il sait
ce qu'est ce genre d'idée de natalité il est
un fanatique de Harry Potter d'accord les règles les
batteurs lancent les cognards sur les poursuivants
avant qu'ils ne puissent faire passer le souaffle à travers
les trois anneaux
Je ne vois
aucun souafle qui vient
du cerveau de génie qui est jugé par
tous les trucs sympas, comment voyez-vous ce
film, vous vous sentirez très privilégié d'être
allé rencontrer Josh Brian, c'est vrai que vos
stagiaires oui sh  mais il est si vieux même si
max je me souviens avoir eu beaucoup de commentaires sur
bien ce n'est pas comme ça que je goûte quelque chose
et puis-je dire ça au lieu de ça parce que
ça leur semble plus organique oh mon dieu
je me sens mal je sens que
je suis juste toi  sais que je pensais que tu étais
important bonne
chance pour ma part, je suis très heureux d'avoir deux
messieurs matures dans l'équipe
ouais
nous continuons à l'appeler camp d'été
regardez les gars je suis désolé mais vous n'aidez pas
vous dites  beaucoup de mots
très vite qui ne signifient rien, il est
fondamentalement beaucoup plus difficile de rester dans le
personnage de ce film que tout ce
que j'ai jamais fait car je regarde juste la
magie se produire et c'est juste hilarant les
gars étaient dans ce truc ensemble alors je suis
vous demandant de croire en vous, de croire les
uns les autres maintenant et la seconde moitié de
ce que vous appelez ce
jeu, mettons nos jambières et
dansons nos culs, venez ici,
petits maniaques adorables qui vous reçoivent
[Musique]